let's now go to someone very different
than Chris Christie and I'm talking
about Ron DeSantis Ron DeSantis put
forth a plan yesterday on Fox News so
insane so ridiculous and so deranged
that even Fox News host Martha McCallum
is visibly skeptical and obviously
doesn't buy it DeSantis was asked
whether he wants to eliminate any
agencies and he mentioned not only three
entire agencies departments Commerce
energy and education but he said he
would eliminate the IRS which is so
ridiculous but then the thing he says
after that is almost worse take a listen
are you in favor of eliminating any
agencies I know conservatives in the
past have talked about closing the
Department of Education would you do
that
so we would do education we would do
Commerce we do energy and we would do
IRS and so if Congress will work with me
on doing that we'll be able to reduce
eliminate the science and scope of
government but what I'm also going to do
Martha is be prepared if Congress won't
go that far I'm going to use those
agencies to push back against woke
ideology and against the leftism that we
see creeping into all institutions of
American life so for example with
Department of Education we reverse all
the transgender sports stuff women's
sports should be protected we reverse
policies trying to inject the curriculum
into our schools that will all be gone
we will make sure we have an
accreditation system for higher ed which
is not trying to foment more things like
Dei and CRT so we'll be prepared to do
both uh either way it'll be a win for
conservatives imagine for a second if a
Democratic presidential candidate said I
will be using the IRS the Department of
Commerce the department of education and
the department of energy to destroy
conservatism imagine for a second if a
Democratic president ever said something
like that they would be calling for
their head they would be saying lock him
or her up Rick Wilson tweeted
uh I'll either eliminate these agencies
or use them to destroy my political
enemies set every authoritarian in the
history of ever this is outrageous this
is a dangerous extremist and by the way
give me a break dude this is in the
style of the Trump promises anyone with
any Common Sense knows it will never
happen he's not going to get rid
certainly he's not going to get rid of
the IRS and I don't think if he was
President he would get rid of the
Department of Education or the
Department of Commerce or the department
of uh energy which was the other one
this is sort of like Mexico is going to
build uh pay to build our wall across
the entire U.S Mexico border and I will
solve the U at the israeli-palestinian
conflict in my first term we all know
you're not doing any of that and after
the fact some people defend it by saying
well it was aspirational it's what he
wanted to do don't we want to hold our
presidential candidates in terms of the
promises they make at least to some
degree
to things that are remotely possible so
this reminds me of the classic moment
where Rick Perry during his failed bid
for the Republican Presidential
nomination also wanted to remove a bunch
of departments but forgot which ones
this is a classic and I will tell you
it's three agencies in government when I
get there that are gone is it Commerce
education and the uh what's the third
one there let's see
all five okay so Commerce education and
uh the uh uh uh EPA EPA there you go
[Applause]
seriously
anyone you were talking about no sir no
sir we were talking about the agencies
of government the EPA needs to be
rebuilt I don't know remove them all but
you can't name the third one
third agency of government I would I
would do away with the education uh the
uh
Commerce and let's see I can't the third
sorry yeah
um listen they're not getting rid of any
of these things but they are
extraordinarily dangerous people and the
fact that DeSantis is willing to say
I'll get rid of the IRS what we of
course need to do if you actually want
to take seriously the idea of people who
are
um not paying their fair share and you
actually need to you need to scale up
the IRS you need to give the IRS the
resources to actually conduct Audits and
we know that the multiplier effect the
return on IRS
um audit agents to Target
extraordinarily High income individuals
is an extremely profitable thing
uh and as I've said before if you hire
an IRA IRS agent for 70 grand and
they're mostly auditing people making 30
grand even if those people underpaid
their taxes by 10 or 15 you're not going
to recover very much money
um but we know that uh the very rich
underpaid I don't mean underpay from a
political or moral standpoint I just
mean they're not paying what the law
currently says they should pay based on
the tax code it's not legal loopholes
it's not they're just they're just
putting in the wrong information they're
not paying what they should pay under
current law it's extremely profitable
from the standpoint of what you pay the
IRS agents versus what you end up
recovering and people who didn't pay
what they're supposed to pay that's the
direction we should go not getting rid
of the IRS but again it's another one of
these virtue signals IRS is now bad it's
political it's it's you know armed
agents blah blah blah uh Rhonda santis
even if he becomes president is not
getting rid of the IRS
think of your most personal emails if
you're using a free email provider you
should know that they're scanning every
email you send and receive even after
you delete it they're usually using the
data to build a picture of your life to
show you ads which many find creepy our
sponsor start mail never scans or tracks
your emails privacy is what comes first
and unlike other email Services when you
delete an email in start mail it is gone
forever it also protects your data by
blocking tracking pixels and emails
which companies and hackers can use to
track you you can create unlimited email
aliases to protect your identity and cut
down on spam you can encrypt every email
you send even if the recipient isn't
using encryption start mail gives you 20
gigs of storage that's more than you get
on Gmail and it only takes a few clicks
to migrate all of your emails and
contacts over to start mail go to
startmail.com Pacman to get 50 off your
first year that's only about two bucks a
month the link is down below